[Musique]
la ministre très mal à l'aise je pense
qu'elle est mal à l'aise pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que il y a des
Bois divergente au sein du gouvernement
sur cette question du coup elle est
l'écriture inclusive et ensuite parce
qu'il y a un vrai sujet de fond qui
concerne l'écriture inclusive est-ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
utiliser pour Noël c'est valider
l'écriture inclusive parce qu'il faudra
bien qu'on me dise si on dit qu'elle est
beau ou il y a les belles donc le sujet
de fond c'est l'écriture inclusive qui
complique la lecture pour les personnes
en situation de handicap et pour les
jeunes la position de la ministre elle
elle relève de l'idéologie en réalité et
elle a elle-même décrit récemment vidéo
comme le fait de mettre dans la tête de
quelqu'un décède et qui n'aurait pas eu
tout seul bien moi je crois qu'en
descendant la neutralité sexuelle la
transidentité l'usage du prénom Yaël on
met dans la tête de l'eau jeune décédé
qui n'aurait jamais eu tout seul ce
gouvernement n'a rien fait pour battre
cette idéologie se moque isthme qui est
à l' œuvre aujourd'hui une idéologie ça
ne se combat pas avec des paroles ça se
trouve avec des messages politiques
claire parce qu'on va avec des textes de
loi 5 ans qui sont totalement ils n'ont
rien
[Musique]